sigamos analizando a detalle los
mercados de competencia perfecta y nos
enfocaremos particularmente en el largo
plazo el largo plazo es el espacio de
tiempo en el cual las empresas pueden
entrar o salir del mercado otra forma de
pensar en ello es que a largo plazo los
costos fijos se vuelven variables se
pueden crear o cerrar fábricas a largo
plazo en vídeos anteriores
hablamos de que a largo plazo en un
mercado de competencia perfecta las
empresas que operan en este mercado
van a tener ganancia económica cero
podemos ver un ejemplo aquí como hemos
visto en muchos vídeos en un mercado de
competencia perfecta las empresas son
precios aceptantes el precio se
establece en el punto de equilibrio
entre la curva de oferta y la curva de
demanda y la empresa acepta ese precio
por lo que es su curva de ingreso
marginal será la recta horizontal que
vemos acá y la ganancia económica cero
ocurre cuando se produce la cantidad en
donde el costo total promedio es igual
al ingreso marginal por cada unidad
adicional la cantidad que se obtiene por
esa unidad marginal es también
cantidad que cuesta producirla pero
recuerden que cuando hablamos de
ganancia económica ésta incluye el costo
de oportunidad esto no quiere decir que
estas empresas operen con una ganancia
contable de cero aún pueden ganar dinero
pero si se toma en cuenta el costo de
oportunidad es ahí cuando la ganancia se
vuelve cero lo que quiero que pensemos
es en lo que sucede a corto plazo y a
largo plazo si algo ocurre en la demanda
del mercado digamos que este es el
mercado de manzanas
este es el mercado general y esta es la
empresa que produce manzanas que puede
ser algún tipo de granja y digamos que
publican un nuevo estudio que dice que
las manzanas son tremendamente buenas
para la salud y que pueden usarse para
mejorar el desempeño deportivo y que
tienen muchas otras propiedades
positivas que es lo que probablemente
ocurra a corto plazo este es un repaso
de lo que hemos visto en términos de las
curvas de la oferta y la demanda y
también queremos saber qué le pasa a la
ganancia económica de la empresa pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en ello a corto
plazo la curva de demanda se desplaza a
la d
porque las personas están dispuestas a
comprar más manzanas sin importar el
precio porque tienen estos nuevos y
emocionantes beneficios así que la curva
de demanda se desplaza más o menos así
esta es de prima y al desplazarse de
esta manera la curva de demanda tenemos
un nuevo precio de equilibrio en el
mercado el nuevo precio de equilibrio en
el mercado se encuentra aquí y también
tenemos una nueva cantidad de equilibrio
la cantidad se desplazó de aquí a acá
así que tenemos una nueva cantidad de
equilibrio y un nuevo precio de
equilibrio que llamamos prima este nuevo
precio de equilibrio indica que hay una
mayor curva de ingreso marginal para la
empresa por lo que ahora es racional
para la empresa a producir una nueva
cantidad recordemos que es racional para
ellos producir hasta que el ingreso
marginal sea igual al costo marginal ya
que cada una de esas unidades
adicionales ganarán dinero hasta ese
punto así que es racional producir esta
nueva cantidad que llamamos q prima en
este nivel la empresa
y está teniendo ganancia económica
porque en esta cantidad tenemos un
ingreso por unidad este es el costo
total promedio por unidad por lo que
obtienen ganancia de esta altura por
unidad que multiplicamos por la cantidad
de unidades producidas que es la base
del rectángulo así que esta área
representa la ganancia económica
positiva pero pueden decir espera un
momento pensé que habías dicho que a
largo plazo las empresas no tienen
ganancia económica en un mercado de
competencia perfecta lo que es cierto al
menos de acuerdo a los modelos que
estamos construyendo porque lo que
sucede cuando se tiene esta ganancia
económica es que otras empresas van a
entrar al mercado cuando hablamos de un
mercado de competencia perfecta no hay
barreras para entrar al mercado todos
son homogéneos y tienen una estructura
de costos similar así que pueden
imaginarse que a largo plazo nuevas
empresas entrarán al mercado por lo que
la curva de la oferta también se va a
desplazar a la derecha y suponiendo que
no cambia la estructura de costos de las
empresas individuales es más vamos a ver
una empresa que acaba de entrar
mercado es la empresa ve y cuando la
empresa entra al mercado tiene la misma
estructura de costos que la empresa y en
ninguna empresa se modifica la
estructura de costos esto se conoce como
mercado de competencia perfecta con
costos constantes donde la entrada o
salida de las empresas no afecta la
estructura de costos de las empresas que
ya están o que entran al mercado en esta
situación las gráficas lucen igual pero
ahora que más empresas entraron al
mercado la curva de la demanda se
desplaza a la derecha y lo seguirá
haciendo hasta que estas empresas que
tienen la misma estructura de costos ya
no tengan alguna ganancia económica no
se desplazará más a la derecha porque no
entran nuevas empresas ahora que hay
pérdida económica sólo se seguirá
desplazando hasta que nadie tenga
ganancia económica vemos lo que sucede
en este mercado de competencia perfecta
con costos constantes donde ahora se ha
regresado a este punto de equilibrio en
donde ahora hay una cantidad mayor
porque a las personas les gustan los
nuevos beneficios de las manzanas pero
donde regresamos al precio que tiene
antes que es la misma curva de ingreso
marginal que teníamos para los diversos
participantes de este mercado cuando
vemos algo como esto en un mercado de
competencia perfecta con costos
constantes se puede crear una curva de
oferta a largo plazo podemos ver lado y
lado prima como curvas de oferta a corto
plazo pero por otra parte la curva de
oferta a largo plazo del mercado en el
que la estructura de costos de las
empresas participantes es independiente
del número de empresas que están dentro
o fuera del mercado podemos ver a la
curva de oferta en lo que llamamos un
mercado de competencia perfecta con
costos constantes que va a ser una recta
horizontal como la que estoy señalando
aquí vamos a detenernos aquí en otros
vídeos veremos qué sucede cuando cambia
la estructura de costos de las empresas
dependiendo de cuántas empresas entran o
salen del mercado y eso se basará en
cómo cambia el costo de los insumos en
la producción conforme entran o salen
empresas